what's going on guys bang bang this week
the Bitcoin update is really focused on
only one thing bitcoin's up about 40 to
start the year it's on track to have the
single best opening to a year since
2013. but why is this happening that is
the big question the first obvious
answer is that people think the fed's
gonna pivot if we see inflation coming
down and the FED does pivot everyone
expects risk assets to take off as we're
watching various assets including
Bitcoin start the year strong that leads
Credence to the idea of the FED pivot
but there's other things at play as well
one of the big Ideas is that the debt
limit hysteria is only going to extend
till June there's a brand new deadline
from the treasury and so the closer and
closer we get to that deadline many
investors are trying to seek safety
somewhere in the market and anything
outside of treasuries or other U.S
government-backed assets will tend to
actually get some sort of benefit you
can think of assets like Bitcoin and
gold being a beneficiary in that
scenario
last but not least it's important to
understand how other investors are
thinking of the market someone like
Barry sternlick at Starwood Capital
recently was on CNBC it was talking
about the idea that interest rates can't
continue to go up because the interest
payments from the US government are
simply getting too large over the last
four years since 2019 the US government
has made between 375 billion and 475
billion dollars a year in interest
payments now that the national debt is
over 31 trillion dollars we have to
start to ask ourselves if a four and a
half or five percent interest rate means
that the US government is going to pay a
trillion dollars a year in interest
payments isn't that going to be a
problem well the White House put out a
budget back in Q4 of last year and they
stated that they believed the interest
payments in 2023 would only be about 400
billion dollars that's a 2.5 x
difference between what the White House
is saying and what it appears that the
actual interest payments are going to be
ultimately big Bitcoin is a chaos hedge
Bitcoin is outside of the system and no
one can manipulate more Bitcoin from
being created so ultimately investors
will continue to seek out Bitcoin in
times of uncertainty or chaos Bitcoin
starting the year up 40 percent when we
have inflation coming down still seeing
interest rate hikes and there's lots of
uncertainty around the debt limit
shouldn't surprise anyone but now all
eyes will turn to the Fed rate decision
next they do 25 basis points that'll end
up being better than if it was 50 or 75
but ultimately many investors they are
seeking out that zero percent interest
rate hike they want to see the FED pivot
wave the white flag and a return back
towards loose monetary policy when that
happens investors are going to be
frantically deploying Capital into the
market and my guess is that Bitcoin will
be a big beneficiary that's it for this
week's update I'll see everyone next
Saturday